The joe rogan experience.
Amazing is the,
all the different shit.
They can put webpages at four,
you know,
so the Webster story,
so,
so I'm,
you know,
at one of these,
um,
network junk,
it's where you go to promote your show and stuff and all the other actors and
cast or they're from the shows.
And this little man,
black kid,
this tall was just cute as can be,
man.
He's like,
I put them on my knee and I started just playing with them and bouncing him
around and he was giggling and laughing and having a good time.
And then like,
you know,
I liked the kids,
I've always liked kids.
So I laid the kid back and I blew like login in his neck.
Sherbert Zuber is that what it's called?
But Dell calls it [inaudible] [inaudible] bloom a couple of desserts and he's
like giggling like a little,
like a little four year old.
Right.
And I put them away in the linen and go ahead now and I'm done playing with you.
And somebody comes over and says,
you know,
he's 16
we,
we're the same age ma'am.
He didn't say anything.
He just laughs.
Oh my God.
That's the best story ever.
Holy Shit you fucking gave the 16 year old Webster observer
on a one on a one to 10.
What was the embarrassment level when you found out he was your age?
It was,
it was you.
I feel.
Really?
What did you think?
I feel bad and I felt gross.
Oh my God.
Gross.
Did you apologize to him?
No.
I'd call my again.
Ever Hide?
No.
Mike are,
you didn't even apologize.
What's he really laughing though when you did it?
Or was he like,
he like if we had to go to training because you had to go back and do it again
today,
would you?
Uh,
would you apologize,
but I apologize.
No,
I just,
he wouldn't apologize
to Batten's humiliating to bed.
There's no cell phone cameras back then.
Could you imagine somebody filming that?
Dude can't.
Melissa Gilbert was teaching me to juggle that day too.
I looked at it.
Jowl.
How?
Okay.
How old was he?
What did he was told it was,
I thought he was like four or five.
I thought it was just like a little kid.
You know,
if we can get them can week a film and recreate it,
reenact it.
What exactly happened with awesome.
I met him once at the comedy store.
He's a very nice guy.
Very nice guy.
He was very friendly.
Oh,
is he a nice guy?
Yeah,
he was fine.
He was,
well,
you guys get killed.
The lovely tastes like sugar.
Yeah.
What did he tastes like?
You remember what he tasted like?
Belly button tastes like honey.
It's old spice.
I only feel bad when I found out how old it was.
Like old spice
was baby gonna fucking stumble.
Babies got razor stubble and a tattoo.
Maybe he's got a heart on.
What the fuck Michael Jackson's glove on his ass.
[inaudible]
hello?
Hello?